hello and welcome to this video playing
chick five you know what line now this
is the decision time
okay this is my line against Leningrad
for quite a while but I never really
studied it which sometimes shows if
somebody is really well versed in it I
sometimes have problems so it seems that
he wants to go with the quick with a
quick e5 but prevent that right away
okay still not so easy to go if v if I
take stakes might be five Julie
prevented so if I go
see you I can go right away for the ecig
square
yeah rook e8 it's not so easy for me to
win this at first
not at first own Miami quickly easily
let's see first of all this has to be
pushed back and now let's open this up I
can take the five right but why can I
not take it maybe still I can think
about malavita no I have to check this
this is better and this I didn't see
that it's not a good good sign but is it
is it great is it great
like everything opens up now
okay so let's take this take a 4 and
then then finally the check I cannot you
hear this also like I can check I can do
this first yeah let's check first check
now see what happens
King of seven queen of sixes is an
immediate disaster I get to check here
just wonder if I have something better
even
don't really am g6 is also hanging which
is kind of nice
okay so I need I need to need all the
pieces of do you want is there anything
better not probably not look a fainter
screen to deform and now we cannot take
only to do two rupee one
Jim
yeah I will
yeah this is probably a theoretical
sorry a theoretical position or very
close c5
Oh a 5 mm yeah but I'm mostly interested
in what we got because that was just
kind of an interesting idea and d5 and
might be six that's a strong move that's
a strong move black intends to of course
now take with the with the piece and if
I take this is this is pretty bad him
I'm accelerating blacks play and he does
a huge hole William oops sorry
so this is y d5 isn't good my g5 move is
a mistake
interesting 595
so here the things are ok he for
threatening a5 and basically forcing the
action here age 6 to do this take afore
I was saying I was expecting this and
then I wanted to go a five-night c8 and
possibly be 5 even though I mean it's
not threatening to take on only six d4
is also making a lot of sense yeah that
is a very good move actually prepare
preventing him from playing you form you
know and this is not going to work I can
take take take take take and this would
even drop this pawn pretty awful so this
is what he did and I went with this and
they have three yeah this is more like
all the obvious moves and and yeah it's
good for white him d5 take didn't see
Queen e6 at all but it's it is so it's
it's just excellent for white maybe two
but this is winning right
c3o justice yeah so it was winning
taking only two didn't help but what do
you do I'm an exchange up and I also
have yeah more chances of an attack here
is king as a bit weak
okay thanks for watching